venise 1966 une montée des eaux
historique
vingt mille habitants sinistrés c'est
acqua alta a duré 48 heures et a
traumatisé les vénitiens pour éviter que
ces images deviennent quotidiennes dans
50 dans 100 ans
il faut entreprendre de grands travaux
dont le prix est coûteux entre les
marées dévastatrices d'un côté et
l'enfoncement de la cité de l'autre
venise risque de disparaître alors
l'italie lance un plan en 1970 pour
sauver la cité des doges en taxant les
cigarettes l'unesco aussi met la main à
la poche en lançant le plan sauver
venise s'agit de sauver une vie n'est
une ville qui a été vivante qui a été
même l'avis même de toutes les villes
italiennes toutes les villes de l'europe
plusieurs projets sont alors à l'étude
et au début des années 70 c'est un
système pour fermer les trois canaux qui
font la jonction entre la mer adriatique
et la lagune qui est retenue on a étudié
sur cette maquette de l'emplacement de
gigantesques et plus qui permettrait de
fermer la lagune dès que la mer monte
l'idée est là encore faut-il la mettre
en place
et pour ça il faudra attendre attendre
en 1988 plus de vingt ans après l'énorme
inondations enfin le projet un prototype
et même un nom moz où moïse en français
venise sauvé des eaux du mois un espoir
ce matin ont eu lieu les premiers essais
de fonctionnement du musée cette
gigantesque écluses expérimental de 20 m
2 au coucher au fond de la lagune en
temps normal et redressez vous le voyez
quand il y à un risque d'inondation
mais le projet patine et déjà dans les
années 90 la gestion financière de cet
énorme chantier est pointé du doigt des
campagnes nationales et internationales
ont été lancés et c'est un véritable
pactole qui a été débloqué
plus de 30 milliards de francs combien
ont été engloutis dans la gabegie et les
détournements de fonds en 2003 soit plus
de 30 ans après le lancement du plan
sauver venise et alors que le prototype
de moïse rouille dans la lagune
le projet est officiellement lancée la
première pierre est posée par silvio
berlusconi lui-même et les journalistes
était encore une fois très confiant le
chantier va durer huit ans on pourra
alors proclamé que venise et s'ouvrir la
fin du projet est alors estimée à
l'époque à 2012
de quoi faire sourire car en 2014 le
projet n'est pas encore terminée et pire
tout un système de corruption et mises à
jour
moïse encore inachevé en 2019 devait
coûter environ 2 milliards d'euros à
l'origine il en est à 5 5 milliards
aujourd'hui
[Musique]